>> Sean: THERE ARE SHORTAGES.
IF PEOPLE CAN HELP, I KNOW THEY
WILL.
WE ARE AMERICANS.
WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
THERE HAS BEEN WAY TOO MUCH
BLAME, WAY TOO MUCH
FINGER-POINTING, WAY TOO MUCH
POLITICIZING AND FEAR AND PANIC
AND HYSTERIA ON THE CORONAVIRUS.
A TON OF FAKE NEWS,
MISINFORMATION GOING AROUND ONCE
AGAIN.
WE ON THIS PROGRAM, WE ARE GOING
TO BE DEDICATED TO BRINGING YOU
FACTS WITHOUT FEAR.
WE ARE AMERICANS.
WE START THIS PROGRAM EVERY
NIGHT WITH THE FACTS FIRST
WITHOUT FEAR.
WE WILL CALL OUT THOSE THAT ARE
SO CORRUPT THAT HAVE NOTHING BUT
A POLITICAL AGENDA.
THAT WOULD INCLUDE THE MEDIA
MOB, MANY OF THEM.
WE CAN SUM IT UP AT THE VERY
BEGINNING OF THE VIRUS,
"NEW YORK TIMES" HEADLINE "THE
TRUMP VIRUS."
IF YOU FEEL AWFUL, YOU KNOW WHO
TO BLAME.
OTHER MULTIPLE OUTLETS CALLING
IT TRUMP’S KATRINA, CHERNOBYL.
WE WILL ANALYZE THE DESTRUCTIVE,
IRRESPONSIBLE BEHAVIOR OF THE
MOB AND THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY BUT
FIRST WE’RE GOING TO START WITH
THE FACTS WITHOUT FEAR.
WHY?
TO HELP KEEP YOUR FAMILY, OUR
AMERICAN FAMILY SAFE AND
HEALTHY.
I HOPE ONE DAY WE GET RID OF
CANCER AND HEART DISEASE.
WE LOSE TENS OF TENS TENS OF
THOUSANDS TO PEOPLE TO FLU EVERY
YEAR.
WE WANT EVERYONE HEALTHY AND
SOUND.
BREAKING NEWS.
I SPENT A CONSIDERABLE AMOUNT OF
TIME SPEAKING WITH LEADERS ALL
WEEKEND AND TODAY FROM THE
PRESIDENT’S TASK FORCE, HERE IS
WHERE WE ARE.
THIS VERY MOMENT IS A CRITICAL
TIME FOR EVERYBODY IN THE
COUNTRY.
MY SOURCES ARE VERY CLEAR
TONIGHT.
WE ARE NOW ENTERING WHAT WILL BE
THE CRUCIAL, DEFINING 15-DAY
PERIOD AS IT RELATES TO THIS
VIRUS.
WE MUST SLOW THE SPREAD OF
CORONAVIRUS.
IF WE ALL JOINED AS AMERICANS,
THE VIRUS DOESN’T DISCRIMINATE
AGAINST REPUBLICAN, DEMOCRAT,
LIBERAL, CONSERVATIVE.
IF WE CAN DO THIS FOR 15 DAYS,
THOUSANDS OF AMERICAN LIVES WILL
BE SAVED.
LOOK AT YOUR SCREEN.
THESE ARE THE RECOMMENDATIONS
FROM THE TASK TASK FORCE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION FROM ALL
AMERICANS.
IF YOU FEEL SICK, STAY AT HOME.
IF YOU WERE KIDS FEEL SICK,
DON’T SEND THEM TO SCHOOL OR
DAY CARE.
IF SOMEONE IN YOUR HOUSEHOLD HAS
TESTED POSITIVE FOR CORONAVIRUS,
PLEASE SELF QUARANTINE YOUR
ENTIRE HOUSEHOLD.
KEEP THEM AT HOME.
IF YOU ARE AN OLDER PERSON OR AN
INDIVIDUAL WITH UNDERLYING
MEDICAL CONDITIONS, A
COMPROMISED IMMUNE SYSTEM, MAYBE
YOU ARE RECEIVING CHEMOTHERAPY,
RADIATION, AUTOIMMUNE ISSUES,
WHATEVER THE UNDERLYING DISEASES
ARE, PLEASE STAY AWAY, ALMOST
QUARANTINE YOURSELF FROM OTHER
PEOPLE.
IT’S CRITICALLY IMPORTANT WE
HEED THESE GUIDELINES ESPECIALLY
IN THIS 15-DAY PERIOD STARTING
TODAY.
IF EVERYBODY DOES THEIR PART IN
THE NEXT TWO WEEKS, WE KNOW FOR
A FACT LIVES WILL BE SAVED.
DON’T BE AFRAID TO BE VIGILANT.
IF YOU NEED MORE INFORMATION,
THERE’S THE WEBSITE.
CORONAVIRUS.GOV.
WE’LL PUT IT UP LATER.
AS THE PRESIDENT SAID EARLIER
TODAY, OUR GAMING FOCUS MUST BE
SLOWING THE SPREAD OF THIS
DISEASE.
FOR THE 15-DAY PERIOD, THE
PRESIDENT IS ASKING ALL
AMERICANS, EVEN THOSE THAT WELL,
DON’T LIKE A SINGLE THING HE’S
DONE, LET’S ALL JOIN TOGETHER IN
THIS EFFORT.
>> MY ADMINISTRATION IS
RECOMMENDING THAT ALL AMERICANS,
INCLUDING THE YOUNG AND HEALTHY,
WORK TO ENGAGE IN SCHOOLING FROM
HOME WHEN POSSIBLE, AVOID
GATHERING IN GROUPS OF MORE THAN
TEN PEOPLE, AVOID DISCUSSION OR
TRAVEL, AND AVOID EATING AND
DRINKING AT BARS, RESTAURANTS,
AND PUBLIC FOOD COURTS.
IF EVERYONE MAKES THIS CHANGE
WHERE THESE CRITICAL CHANGES AND
SACRIFICES NOW, WE WILL RALLY
TOGETHER AS ONE NATION AND WE
WILL DEFEAT THE VIRUS.
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE A BIG
CELEBRATION ALTOGETHER.
>> Sean: THE PRESIDENT’S
RIGHT.
WE ARE FIGHTING AN INVISIBLE
ENEMY AND NOW SLOWING THE SPREAD
IS CRUCIAL AND KEY.
LUCKILY IN THIS CASE SOME PRETTY
BASIC STEPS BY ALL OF US
TOGETHER WILL GO A VERY LONG
WAY.
FOR EXAMPLE MANY AMERICANS ARE
NOW WORKING REMOTELY.
THANK GOD FOR TECHNOLOGY.
NUMEROUS SCHOOLS, UNIVERSITIES,
THEY ARE UTILIZING ONLINE
LEARNING.
ANOTHER GREAT PROGRESS.
THOUSANDS OF BARS, RESTAURANTS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY ARE NOW
LIMITING SERVICE TO TAKEOUT AND
DELIVERY.
I WANT THESE GUYS TO KEEP
STAYING IN BUSINESS, SO I’M
TRYING TO PATRONIZE ALL THE
BUSINESSES I KNOW.
TONIGHT ESPECIALLY LOCAL
BUSINESS.
IT’S CRITICALLY IMPORTANT THAT
YOU PRACTICE GREAT HYGIENE AND
WHAT WE CALL SOCIAL DISTANCING.
ACCORDING TO THE STUDIES, THIS
VIRUS IS THREE TIMES MORE
CONTAGIOUS THAN THE FLU.
FROM THE BEGINNING, YOU REMEMBER
OUR COVERAGE, WE WERE TELLING
YOU WE NOTICED THAT PEOPLE WITH
VIRTUALLY NO SYMPTOMS OR NONE
WHATSOEVER, THEY WERE CAPABLE OF
UNKNOWINGLY PASSING IT ON TO
OTHERS.
WHILE MOST YOUNG PEOPLE, UNLIKE
EACH ONE AND ONE, WELL, THEY
DON’T EXPERIENCE, SOMETIMES NO
SYMPTOMS ARE NOT SEVERE
SYMPTOMS, MILD SYMPTOMS.
THEY CAN SPREAD THIS DISEASE
LIKE WILDFIRE.
THE OVERWHELMING PEOPLE THAT DO
CONTRACT THE DISEASE, AGAIN, NO
SYMPTOMS, MILD SYMPTOMS OR YOU
WILL GET THE FLU BUT FULLY
RECOVER.
IF THEY BY THE WAY AROUND THOSE
WITH THOSE UNDERLYING
CONDITIONS, COMPROMISED IMMUNE
SYSTEMS, AND THEY PASS ON THIS
VIRUS, WE RISK LOSING THOSE
LIVES.
THAT’S WHY THIS IS IMPORTANT.
AS I’VE BEEN SAYING, LET’S
PROTECT OUR GRANDMOTHERS, OUR
GRANDPARENTS, OLDER MOMS AND
DADS.
THAT’S WHAT THIS 15-DAY PERIOD
IS ALL ABOUT.
WE ARE THE LAND OF THE FREE IN
THE HOME OF THE BRAVE.
THESE ARE NOT JUST WORDS IN AN
ANTHEM.
THAT IS WHO WE ARE AS A PEOPLE.
IT’S IN OUR DNA.
I ALWAYS SAY LET NOT YOUR HEARTS
BE TROUBLED.
WE ARE GOING TO GET THROUGH
THIS.
DURING HIS FIRST INAUGURAL
ADDRESS HE MADE A MEMBER OF
PRESIDENT ROOSEVELT REASSURING
AMERICANS DURING A TIME OF RATE
UNCERTAINTY, SAYING THE ONLY
THING WE HAVE TO FEAR IS FEAR
ITSELF.
FEAR IS NOT HELPING HERE.
THOSE ADVANCING POLITICAL
AGENDAS, THEY ARE NOT HELPING
EITHER.
86 YEARS LATER THOSE WORDS, THEY
STILL RING TRUE TODAY I ENDED A
FEW SHORT DECADES, THIS COUNTRY
DEFEATED LET’S SEE, NAZISM,
FASCISM, COMMUNISM, IMPERIAL
JAPAN, WE MADE IT THROUGH THE
GREAT DEPRESSION, THE GREAT
RECESSION, 9/11, THE COLD WAR,
WE ARE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
WE FACE OUR PROBLEMS HEAD-ON,
RISE TO THE OCCASION.
OVERCOME OUR CHALLENGES NO
MATTER WHAT WITH THE GREATEST
LAST MEDICAL RESEARCHERS,
SCIENTISTS, DOCTORS AND THE
ENTIRE WORLD.
THE CORONAVIRUS IS NO DIFFERENT.
SO FAR THERE’VE BEEN UNDER
200,000 CONFIRMED CASES
WORLDWIDE.
181,377.
I HAVE AN UPDATED NUMBER.
MORE THAN 7,000 DEATHS.
THE GOAL IS TO SAVE AS MANY
LIVES HERE IN AMERICA AND
WORLDWIDE AS POSSIBLE.
AT HOME IN AMERICA 3,800
AMERICANS OF TESTED POSITIVE FOR
THE DISEASE.
FACTS WITHOUT FEAR.
LESS THAN 100 HAVE DIED.
THOSE NUMBERS WILL RISE LIKELY
DRAMATICALLY WITH MORE TESTING.
THE NUMBERS THAT HAVE CONTRACTED
THE DISEASE.
IT’S EXPECTED IF EVERYBODY DOES
THEIR PART IT WILL LEVEL OFF.
THE SOONER THE BETTER.
FOR CONTEXT, A LOT OF PEOPLE
DON’T SEEM TO KNOW THIS.
THIS IS WHY THE FEARMONGERING
AND THE PANIC AND THE HYPE AND
HYSTERIA IS SO UNHELPFUL.
LAST YEAR OVER 35 MILLION
AMERICANS CONTRACTED THE FLU.
OVER 490,000 AMERICANS
HOSPITALIZED FOR THE FLU.
34,000 AMERICANS DIED OF THE
FLU.
RIGHT HERE IN THE UNITED STATES
OVER THE COURSE OF JUST ONE
YEAR.
THAT’S PRETTY TYPICAL.
NOW THANKFULLY THE TOLL
SURROUNDING CORONAVIRUS IS
LOWER.
HOWEVER, FACTS WITHOUT FEAR.
IF WE TAKE ALL THE NECESSARY
PRECAUTIONS, THE STATS WILL
LEVEL OFF AND ULTIMATELY BEGIN A
DECLINE AND HOPEFULLY FOUR TO
SIX WEEKS MAX AND WE CAN GET
BACK TO LIFE AS NORMAL.
TONIGHT WE MUST DO WHATEVER IS
NECESSARY TO STOP THE SPREAD OF
THE DISEASE.
PROTECT OUR OLDER FELLOW
AMERICANS, FLATTEN THAT CURVE
AND MORE IMPORTANTLY SAVE LIVES.
WE CAN SAY THIS TONIGHT WITHOUT
A DOUBT.
THE PRESIDENTS CHINA AND
EUROPEAN TRAVEL BAN I PREDICT
WILL GO DOWN AS THE SINGLE MOST
CONSEQUENTIAL DECISION IN
HISTORY.
THAT’S NOT POLITICAL.
IT BROUGHT US TIME.
IT BOUGHT HOSPITAL’S TIME.
TO PREPARE FOR THE WORST-CASE
SCENARIO.
IT BOUGHT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
TIME TO THE SOURCE VENTILATORS
AND OTHER MEDICAL SUPPLIES.
IT BOUGHT DOCTORS, SCIENTISTS,
RESEARCHERS TIME TO DEVELOP
EITHER TREATMENTS AND EVENTUALLY
HOPEFULLY A VACCINE.
IT BOUGHT THE PHARMACEUTICAL
INDUSTRY TIME SO THEY CAN DO
WHAT THEY DO BEST.
IN FACT, THE VERY FIRST
EXPERIMENT OF VACCINE IN THE
U.S. WAS TESTED TODAY.
EARLIER TODAY.
LET’S NOT FORGET IT ALSO BOUGHT
ENOUGH TIME FOR AN UNPRECEDENTED
PUBLIC-PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP TO
FORM AS THE PRESIDENT ANNOUNCED
FRIDAY.
I WOULD SAY BETWEEN, WITHIN
THREE WEEKS OF US IDENTIFYING
THE VIRUS, THEN THE TRAVEL BAN
QUARANTINE, THIS UNPRECEDENTED
PUBLIC-PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP WHERE
WERE GO TO PARKING LOTS OF
WALMART, WALGREENS, CVS, I DON’T
WANT TO FORGET THE GREAT
COMPANIES HELPING AND WE ARE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO DO SOMETHING
WE’VE NEVER BEEN ABLE TO DO
BEFORE IN RECORD SPEED.
A GROUNDBREAKING NEW SYSTEM, NEW
PARADIGM DRIVE THROUGH TESTING
SITES.
IT IN THE WORKS.
ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY WITH MANY
LOCATIONS ALREADY OPEN IN RECORD
TIME.
TODAY EVEN THE MEDIA MOB, THEY
SHOWED, MAYBE THEY WERE SICK
TODAY.
SLIGHT SIGNS OF MODERATE
RESTRAINT.
IT WASN’T ALL GOTCHA QUESTIONS
AND PERSONAL ATTACKS.
HOWEVER SADLY, THERE ARE THOSE
WHO WILL ALWAYS BE MORE
INTERESTED IN BLUDGEONING THE
PRESIDENT POLITICALLY THAN
ACTUALLY SOLVING A PROBLEM.
IN THIS CASE, A PANDEMIC.
SADLY PANDEMIC HAPPENED.
I WISH THEY NEVER HAPPEN.
IT BRINGS US TO THE POLITICS OF
THIS VIRUS.
CONTEXT IS IMPORTANT IN LIFE.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS TIME LINE.
THIS IS DIFFERENT.
PUT TOGETHER BY JOEL POLLOCK.
LOOK AT THIS.
JANUARY 21ST, THE VERY FIRST
PERSON WITH CORONAVIRUS ARRIVED
IN THE U.S. FROM CHINA.
THAT’S NOT LONG AGO.
THE SAME TIME, DEMOCRATS, WHAT
WERE THEY DOING?
THEY WERE IN THE THROES OF AN
ALL-CONSUMING, WHAT HAS BEEN THE
CULMINATION OF A THREE YEAR
QUEST TO IMPEACH AND THROW
DONALD TRUMP OUT OF OFFICE, UNDO
AN ELECTION.
THEY NEVER ACCEPTED THE RESULTS
OF IN THE BEGINNING.
JANUARY 23RD, HOUSE IMPEACHMENT
MANAGERS, WHAT WERE THEY DOING?
OH, THEY WERE DOING THEIR
OPENING ARGUMENTS AND
IMPEACHMENT.
SAME DAY, CHINA COMPLETELY
SEALED OFF THE ENTIRE PROVINCE
OF WUHAN.
THEN ON JANUARY 31ST, LOOK AT
THIS.
THE PRESIDENT THEN DECLARED THAT
NATIONAL HEALTH EMERGENCY,
ORDERED MANDATORY TWO WEEK
QUARANTINES.
HE ISSUED THE TRAVEL BAN ON ALL
TRAVEL TO AND FROM CHINA.
ON THAT SAME DAY, WHAT WERE THE
DEMOCRATS DOING?
THEY WERE BUSY WITH IMPEACHING
THE PRESIDENT.
THEY WEREN’T CARING.
JANUARY 31, SENATE DEMOCRATS
DESPERATELY PUSHING FOR MORE
IMPEACHMENT WITNESSES, THE DAY
DONALD TRUMP WITH THE TRAVEL BAN
QUARANTINE IN EFFECT.
WOW.
IT WASN’T UNTIL FEBRUARY 5 THAT
THE IMPEACHMENT CHARADE WAS
OFFICIALLY OVER AND EVEN THEN,
MANY WERE PLOTTING FUTURE
IMPEACHMENT INVESTIGATIONS.
THE NEXT ONE.
MEANWHILE OTHER TOP DEMOCRATS
WERE CALLING THE PRESIDENT’S
TRAVEL BAN RACIST.
JANUARY 31, THE DAY OF THE
TRAVEL BAN, WHAT DID
QUID PRO QUO JOE SAY ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT’S ACTIONS?
HE SAID THEY WERE XENOPHOBIC,
THEY WERE HYSTERICAL IN THE
PRESIDENT WAS FEARMONGERING.
NO, JOE.
YOU’RE WRONG.
DEMOCRAT HOUSE MEMBERS, THEY
WERE WORRIED THAT THE BAN WOULD
STOKE RACIAL DETERMINATION.
NO PRESIDENT HAS DONE MORE OR
ACTED QUICKER TO STOP THE SPREAD
OF A PANDEMIC OR DISEASE AND
YET, THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN
TRASHED EVERY STEP OF THE WAY BY
DEMOCRATS AND OF COURSE THEIR
STATE RUN TV IN THE MEDIA MOB.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE ARE WORKING VERY STRONGLY
WITH CHINA ON THE CORONAVIRUS.
>> THIS IS NO TIME FOR
DONALD TRUMP’S RECORD OF
HYSTERIA, XENOPHOBIA.
>> I HAVE TODAY DECLARED THAT
THEY CORONAVIRUS PRESENTS A
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY IN THE
UNITED STATES.
>> WE HAVE A CRISIS OF
CORONAVIRUS AND PRESIDENT TRUMP
HAS NO PLAN.
>> WE HAVE STOPPED NON-U.S.
CITIZENS FROM COMING IN TO
AMERICA FROM CHINA.
THAT WAS DONE VERY EARLY ON.
WE ARE SCREENING PEOPLE AND WE
HAVE BEEN AT A VERY HIGH LEVEL.
WE ARE WORKING VERY HARD TO
EXPEDITE THE LONGER PROCESS OF
DEVELOPING A VACCINE.
>> WE HAVE TO JUST STIPULATE TO
FACT.
WE HAVE TO DISPEL SOME OF THE
MISINFORMATION.
>> TO UNLEASH THE FULL POWER OF
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IN THIS
EFFORT TODAY, I AM OFFICIALLY
DECLARING A NATIONAL EMERGENCY.
>> SHOT THIS PRESIDENT UP RIGHT
NOW BECAUSE HE IS UNDERMINING
THE DOCTORS AND SCIENTISTS
>> Sean: LAST NIGHT YOU HAD
DOCTORS BE 27 JOE AND
DR. BOLSHEVIK BERNIE SANDERS
MAKING IT CLEAR THEY WOULD NEVER
HAVE ENACTED THE TRAVEL
BAN TO STOP THE SPREAD OF
CORONAVIRUS.
THAT WOULD’VE BEEN THE SINGLE
BIGGEST MISTAKE THAT WOULD’VE
RESULTED IN THOUSANDS OF
AMERICANS CONTRACTING THE
DISEASE AND UNTOLD NUMBERS
DYING.
THEY WANT COMPLETELY OPEN
BORDERS, EVEN STILL.
UNCHECKED IMMIGRATION.
THEY BOTH WALKED GOVERNMENT RUN
FREE HEALTH CARE FOR ALL,
INCLUDING ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
YEAH, THIS IS GOING TO BE VERY
EXPENSIVE AT THE END OF THE DAY.
THOSE TWO BOZOS, THEY DIDN’T
QUITE GET IT AND IT’S LIKELY
THOUSANDS OF AMERICANS WOULD
HAVE CONTRACTED THE VIRUS AND
MANY OTHER AMERICANS DIED FROM
IT.
AMERICA’S BORDERS AS WE’VE BEEN
SAYING, HAVE GOT TO BE SAFE.
TESTING, SCREENING THOSE WHO
HAVE COME INTO OUR COUNTRY,
THAT’S ONE ASPECT OF IT.
ALSO WE DON’T WANT PEOPLE WITH
RADICAL AGENDAS.
WE WANT PEOPLE ABLE TO TAKE CARE
OF THEMSELVES IF WE DO INVITE
THEM INTO OUR COUNTRY.
WE DON’T CARE WHERE YOU COME
FROM.
LET US VENT YOU.
OUR HEALTH CARE SYSTEM WHILE NOT
PERFECT PRODUCES THE BEST
DOCTORS, MEDICINE, RESEARCH
ANYWHERE IN THE WORLD BUT
DR. QUID PRO QUO JOE IS TELLING
VOTERS HE WOULD’VE DONE A BETTER
JOB AS PRESIDENT THAT HIS
SOCIALIST IDEAS OF ALL, HE WANTS
TO EXPAND OBAMACARE.
MILLIONS LOST THEIR DOCTORS.
MILLIONS LOST THEIR PLANS.
ON AVERAGE PAYING 200% MORE.
37% OF AMERICANS HAVE ONE
OBAMA-BIDEN CARE EXCHANGE
OPTION.
THIS IS THE SAME GUY WHO CAN’T
GET THROUGH A DIGITAL TOWN HALL
SATURDAY WITHOUT TURNING IT INTO
A COMPLETE AND TOTAL DISASTER.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE WHOLE POINT IS WE CAN DO
A LOT TO DEAL WITH IT.
WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH THIS
NATIONAL BASIS.
RIGHT NOW FOR EXAMPLE, WE HAVE A
THING, BRAZIL, THE AMAZON IS
BURNING.
I’M SORRY THIS HAS BEEN SUCH A
DISJOINTED EFFORT HERE BECAUSE
OF THE CONNECTIONS.
THERE’S A LOT MORE TO SAY.
I’VE ALREADY PROBABLY SAID TOO
MUCH TO YOU.
>> Sean: IN 232 DAYS, YOU THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE -- OH, I’M SORRY
FOR THE CAMERAS OVER HERE.
IT DOESN’T SAY HANNITY FOR
PRESIDENT OR ANYTHING.
START INTO A HALF HOURS LATE.
232 DAYS, YOU WILL DECIDE
WHETHER THAT MAN HOLDS THE KEYS
TO THE MOST POWERFUL JOB IN THE
WORLD.
A CRITICAL DECISION.
WE ARE WITNESSING THE
PRESIDENT’S ACTIONS CAN HAVE
MAJOR AND MASSIVE RAMIFICATIONS.
THIS NEW PARADIGM, LET’S SEE,
OH, PUBLIC-PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP,
TRAVEL BAN, QUARANTINES, ACTING
IN UNPRECEDENTED -- WITH
UNPRECEDENTED QUICKNESS.
THIS WILL CHANGE HOW WE DEAL
WITH FUTURE PANDEMICS AND SAVE
LIVES.
THE REGULATION CUTTING IS
HELPING SPEED THE DEVELOPMENT OF
A VACCINE.
THE EMERGENCY DECLARATION
ENABLED AN UNPRECEDENTED
PUBLIC-PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP WITH
ALL THE MONEY THAT WILL BE
NEEDED TO FUND IT.
GOING FORWARD, THE PRESIDENT’S
COMMITMENT TO HELPING AMERICAN
BUSINESSES WILL HAVE, WELL,
LASTING EFFECTS.
GOT TO HELP OUR FELLOW
BUSINESSES IN TROUBLE.
AIRLINE INDUSTRY, CRUISE
INDUSTRY, THOSE WORKERS.
HOURLY WORKERS WHO FEAR TAKING A
DAY OR A COUPLE DAYS OFF BECAUSE
THEY ARE NOT FEELING WELL.
THEY ARE ALL HANDLED UNDER THE
PRESIDENT’S PLAN ALREADY.
JOE, I HAVE A PLAN.
THE PRESIDENT DID ALL THE THINGS
YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT AND THEN
SOME.
NOW IS NOT THE TIME FOR
WASHINGTON TO TO PLAY GAMES.
ALL HANDS ON DECK.
GOVERNMENTS MUST WORK TOGETHER
AND GET HOSPITALS WHAT THEY
NEED, EQUIPMENT THAT MIGHT BE
NEEDED, THE SUPPLIES THEY MAY
NEED IN THE FUTURE.
NEWT GINGRICH HAD A GREAT IDEA.
USE THE FLOATING NAVAL VESSELS
THAT WE ALREADY HAVE.
WE ALREADY HAVE FLOATING
HOSPITALS.
WE CAN USE THOSE.
MAYBE WE CAN EVEN COMMANDEER OR
RENT OR BUY TEMPORARILY MAYBE
THESE CRUISE SHIPS.
RATHER THAN JUST A BAILOUT.
WE CAN HOUSE PEOPLE THAT NEED
HELP.
OF COURSE, WE ARE NOT AT THAT
POINT.
WE DON’T WANT TO GET TO THAT
WE NEED TO PREPARE FOR THE WORSE
CASE SCENARIO.
THE PRESIDENT HAS TASK FORCE
CONFIRMED THEY ARE.
AS IT STANDS, OUR HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM HAS ADEQUATE VENTILATORS,
ICU BEDS, MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS
AND ULTIMATELY LIKE I SAID WE